[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le jeudi 22 juin voici le programme de
ce soir quels sont les informations à
retenir aujourd'hui dans les Yvelines le
passage au 30 km/h d'une commune
yvelinoise la disparition d'une célèbre
mascotte ou encore du sport cette nuit
le basketteur Yves Dunois Victor
whenbanyama connaîtra dans quelle équipe
il jouera aux États-Unis de la musique
sous toutes ses formes métal jazz rock
gospel des matchs d'improvisation ou
encore du théâtre et du cirque l'espace
Albert Camus de Maurepas a dévoilé sa
nouvelle saison culturelle on en parle
avec l'adjointe au maire à la culture de
la ville et puis comme d'habitude le
jeudi à l'approche du week-end nous vous
donnerons nos idées de sortie dans les
Yvelines au programme la saison des
cueillettes dans le département la fête
de la musique qui se prolonge samedi et
dimanche ou encore la journée olympique
au golf national et ce sera enfin
démission dans notre partie loisirs pour
le moment avec moi un plateau et la
directrice du centre de formation
d'apprentis de Versailles Cécile perroté
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous avez
participé avec des jeunes à la troisième
édition du Salon de la pâtisserie je
suppose que c'était un honneur un
privilège pour vous d'y être oui bien
sûr oui c'est toujours un honneur de
participer à des événements en dehors du
CFA ça intéressant on a pu proposer
quelques chefs préparées par nos
apprentis modestement mais qui ont fait
leur effet et puis on a également
assisté à un des chefs pâtissier du
Jules Verne dans la décoration des
gâteaux avec le thème fête des pères
donc c'est une belle expérience oui
tout à l'heure dans cette émission nous
parlerons aussi de culture le théâtre
Albert qui a eu deux morts pas à
dévoiler sa nouvelle saison culturelle
je vous le disais à l'instant pour en
parler avec nous Véronique rocher
l'adjointe au maire à la culture de la
commune bonsoir bonsoir alors en
quelques mots à quoi faut-il s'attendre
pour cette nouvelle saison culturelle un
parcours parcours très riche d'un
univers très riche très varié
musicale théâtrale vous avez parlé de
cirque
exposition
on va inviter aussi un auteur de
Maurepas qui vit joue qui est
scénographe et acteurs et qui va venir
nous présenter à l'occasion du maurepark
tout son travail donc voilà c'est très
très varié et donc on parlera de toute
cette programmation en détail dans
quelques instants sur le plateau
également notre chroniqueuse sur le
bien-être animal à Tiz barré bonsoir
bonsoir Mathilde alors de quoi est-ce
que vous allez nous parler ce soir c'est
la canicule on souffre de la chaleur
donc je vais vous donner ce soir
quelques conseils pour pouvoir
rafraîchir votre animal alors
aujourd'hui il pleuvait un petit peu
c'était un petit peu moins chaud mais
certainement qu'il va faire très très
chaud dans les jours à venir donc on
aura hâte d'entendre vos conseils et
enfin nous sommes aussi accompagnés d'un
journaliste de la rédaction de TV 78
mais qu'elle a mis de Robert vous allez
nous présenter les informations à
retenir aujourd'hui dans les Yvelines ce
sera juste après la météo de demain
matin nous devrions avoir de nouveau du
soleil dans les Yvelines avec quelques
éclaircies au niveau des températures ça
reste toujours un peu frais le matin il
fera 18 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie
Versailles et Houdan et 17 degrés à
Rambouillet dans l'après-midi le ciel
sera toujours assez dégagé côté
température il fera 25 degrés à
Versailles 26 degrés à Rambouillet et
aux dents et 27 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie
et demain nous fêterons les Audrey le
pont maintenant sur les informations du
jour à retenir dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
et on commence ces informations du jour
Michael par une image oui on commence
par une image impressionnante regardez
celle d'un camion qui a brûlé ce matin
sur la 12 entre le vélo Drôme national
de 50 ans en ligne et le siège de BMX
France sans direction à Paris des
cartons de vêtements situés dans la
remorque compris feu pour une raison
inconnue 5 véhicules de pompiers de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et de Maurepas ce
sont déplacés sur le lieu de l'incident
pour éteindre les flammes direction
Bois-d'Arcy à présent il faudra
désormais lever le pied dans la ville et
oui à Mathilde de la vitesse est
désormais illimitée à 30 km/h sur la
quasi-totalité de la ville de
Bois-d'Arcy les axes principaux comme la
rue Jean Jaurès restent à 50 km/h des
contrôles de police seront effectués
régulièrement mais ils feront preuve de
pédagogie dans un premier temps cette
limitation doit permettre une réduction
du bruit de la pollution dans la commune
selon à la mairie et on va maintenant
partir du côté de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
pour parler de la Fête des Loges il va y
avoir du changement au niveau visuel
l'organisation de la fête moi j'ai
dévoilé la nouvelle affiche officielle
de l'édition 2023 et je ne sais pas si
vous l'avez remarqué il n'y a plus la
fameuse mascotte le renard mousquetaire
sur la fiche cette dernière apparaissait
sur les affiches autour de ce
rendez-vous depuis 2006 la raison les
organisateurs voulaient une affiche plus
épurée que les précédentes et ont donc
décidé de retirer la mascotte baptisée
funny Lodge même sans son renard la Fête
des Loges devrait attirer plusieurs
milliers de personnes dans la forêt de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye la Fête des Loges
débutera le 30 juin prochain dura
jusqu'au 20 août il y aura encore cette
année près de 200 attractions et on va
maintenant parler d'un festival
historique dans les Yvelines l'Estival
reviendra cette année pour une 36e
édition l'événement sera organisé du 16
septembre au 7 octobre sur les communes
de Poissy d'Achères de houx du PEC et de
Montesson et on connaît enfin la
programmation parmi les têtes d'affiches
on retrouvera Camille Lellouche au
théâtre de Poissy le 22 septembre et
Louis Chedid le 1er octobre également à
Poissy et Chimène Badi viendra revisiter
les chansons d'Édith Piaf l'or le
festival la programmation complète est à
retrouver sur le site du festival une
belle programmation en perspective en
termes on a hâte d'y être on termine
avec du sport Michael le destin d'un
yvelinois va changer ce soir une nuit
qui va tout changer pour le basketteur
ivinois Victor weba nyama le sportif de
19 ans va connaître sa future équipe
dans le championnat américain il devrait
être choisi cette nuit comme premier
choix de la draft NBA une sorte de
bourse aux jeunes joueurs qui permet aux
équipes américaines de recruter les plus
grands talents de la planète sauf
retournement de situation il devrait
rejoindre les San Antonio Spurs l'équipe
l'ancienne équipe de Tony Parker et
devenir le premier Français de
l'histoire à être sélectionné à cette
place de numéro 1 si vous voulez voir ce
rendez-vous historique pour le basket
français et voir le destin du joueur
originaire du Chesnay Rocancourt
basculer c'est à partir de deux heures
cette nuit vous allez vous lever
Mathilde je pense que je serai en train
de dormir
merci beaucoup Mickaël midoro pour
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
image ou une information qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le hashtag 78 news
un peu de gourmandise dans votre sept
huit le week-end dernier la chambre de
métier et de l'artisanat à dilde de
France c'était présente pour la
troisième édition du Salon de la
pâtisserie et sur place était également
présent une dizaine d'apprentis du
centre de formation d'apprentis de
Versailles ils ont pu assister des
grands chefs pour en parler avec nous
Cécile Perrotet la directrice du CFA de
Versailles et Gaëlle mollet bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes un ancien
apprenti du CFA de Versailles et vous
avez également ouvert votre propre
boulangerie pâtisserie les traditions de
bennes alors avant de parler de votre
boulangerie pâtisserie on va revenir sur
le salon de la pâtisserie comment est-ce
que s'est déroulé cette journée en fait
c'était trois jours puisque c'est un
week-end complet plus un lundi en
général sur les samedis dimanches il y a
énormément de monde parce que c'est
ouvert au grand public et on nous avons
fait des pièces ce qu'on appelle les
pièces en sucre qui ont été réalisées et
l'équipe des apprentis du CFA donc sont
des pièces un peu magistral qui vont qui
vont être avec du sucre soufflé avec des
fleurs avec du sucre tiré donc c'est un
travail très méticuleux ils est très
chaud donc c'était un peu tendu pour
tout faire tenir mais ça a été deux
belles réussites sur ces sur ces trois
jours et puis beaucoup d'échanges avec
les professionnels sur le salon c'est
important pour les jeunes de prendre
contact avec les professionnels de
découvrir des nouvelles choses et des
nouveaux produits ils peuvent apprendre
des techniques particulières je suppose
oui ben comme je disais tout à l'heure
ils ont ils ont assisté ce chef du Jules
Verne chef pâtissier du Jules Verne ils
ont donc vu comment on faisait des
décorations de façon un peu différente
toujours avec des fruits de saison avec
avec des pâte à sucre avec des décors
pour la fête des pères parce que c'était
le thème du week-end qui était bien
choisi puisque ça tombait parfaitement
et puis également vu il y avait
énormément de de propositions de de
d'échanges avec les professionnels il y
avait des petits forums des réussite des
échanges particuliers aussi donc ça
c'était un point fort également ils
avaient quoi concrètement comme comme
tâche comme mission confiée par le chef
du Jules Verne et bien c'était on devait
donc donner des propositions de décor
sur ce thème là faire des propositions
avec parfois de la pâte d'amande parfois
de la pâte des pâtes de fruits des
fruits comme je disais tout à l'heure
des fruits de saison et puis il devait
créer à peu près il y a eu à peu près
300 entremets qui ont été vendus sur ces
deux jours le samedi le dimanche donc
deux fois 306 en gâteau à préparer et à
décorer dans leur intégralité donc ça
c'était un vrai challenge oui c'était
c'est tendu mais on est arrivé et ça
s'est très bien passé mais ça va ils
s'en sont bien sortis oui ça va bah ils
étaient contents ils ont ils ont réalisé
ça de manière efficace alors les
conditions sont pas celles d'un
laboratoire classique donc voilà on se
presse tout est pas à disposition tout
est pas tout de suite là présent donc il
faut s'adapter et ça c'est important
dans le métier de pouvoir s'adapter à
toutes les situations quand on veut
évoluer après sur d'autres d'autres
ateliers et d'autres d'autres enseignes
ont tiré quoi comme comme l'expérience
ils ont apprécié oui alors comme
expérience c'est cette situation qui
était en situation particulière dans un
lieu non climatique par exemple mais
travailler à contact d'autres personnes
ils sont souvent avec leur maître
d'apprentissage leur collègues depuis
deux ans lorsqu'ils font une formation
donc là on sort un petit peu du cadre et
ça c'est important ça ça favorise de
nouvelles compétences ça permet
d'échanger différemment de voir d'autres
techniques ça c'est un gros point fort
donc ça c'est important pour les BTM et
puis pour toutes les la filière
pâtisserie vous êtes déjà rendu au salon
de la pâtisserie photos de splatoon
j'espère avec impatience qu'on pourra
aussi y participer à nouveau et être
présent pour pour à nouveau travailler
sur des gâteaux ou d'autres d'autres
choses en pâtisserie je suppose que vous
Gael Monnet vous y êtes déjà rendu j'y
suis déjà avec plusieurs fois
c'est un rendez-vous incontournable pour
au milieu de la pâtisserie
mais c'est sympa d'aller voir ce qu'ils
font donc je disais tout à l'heure où
vous êtes un ancien apprenti du CFA de
Versailles quels cursus vous avez suivi
moi j'ai commencé il y a 12 ans enfin
CAP Pâtissier après j'ai enchaîné avec
un CAP boulanger et après j'ai fait un
BTM en deux ans donc c'était ça remonte
il y a 12 ans mais voilà
je suis venu j'ai réussi à cette année
encore les CAP il y a un juste retour
des choses quoi on n'oublie pas d'où on
vient et c'est important de former les
jeunes pour que ils reprennent le
flambeau après moi dans la pâtisserie où
j'ai commencé bah maintenant vu qu'on
est pas très loin je l'ai je les dépanne
quand ils ont besoin et je trouve que
c'est plus sympa quand ça se passe comme
ça qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce qu'elle
vous a apporté votre formation
un côté professionnel quoi
un but quoi
il y a plein de jeunes qui savent pas
trop ce qu'ils veulent faire moi dès 15
ans j'ai su que c'était ça que je
voulais faire et je m'y suis accroché et
maintenant ça fait trois ans que j'ai
ouvert mon commerce à 15 ans c'était une
évidence pour vous à 15 ans j'ai fait un
stage en 4e
en 3e j'ai fait un stage j'ai su que
c'était ça que je voulais faire et dès
la de la sortie de 3e je me suis lancé
là-dedans pourquoi
je vous avais c'était là-dedans que vous
vouliez vous lancer absolument parce que
pour moi c'est du concret tu fabriques
les trucs tu vois le résultat tout de
suite
s'il y a pas de
voilà c'est tu fais des choses de tes
mains
alors aujourd'hui vous avez votre propre
boulangerie pâtisserie les traditions de
ben c'est une concrétisation pour vous
oui moi quand j'ai commencé je voulais
ouvrir mon commerce des 15 ans je savais
que c'est ce que je voulais faire après
je pensais pas trouver dans ma ville
natale donc c'est encore mieux mais
en tout cas je suis très content parce
qu'en fait il y a plein de clients que
je vois qui que c'est des gens que je
connais en fait et vraiment au quotidien
ça je dirais que c'est encore mieux
parce que c'est voilà c'est des amis
c'est des rencontres des gens que je
connais depuis très longtemps depuis que
je suis tout petit qui vient de me dire
franchement on adore ce que tu fais
continue comme ça c'est génial c'est que
du bonheur quoi est-ce que vous subissez
quand même quelques difficultés il y a
l'inflation et la crise énergétique ça a
été oui compliqué comme tout le monde
mais après moi j'ai eu cette chance ou
franchement on
n'a pas subi de plein fouet
j'ai tout de suite quand dès qu'on a
commencé ça a marché tout de suite très
fort en trois ans on a quadruplé le
chiffre d'affaires je suis passé de 4
salariés à 11 et l'année prochaine je
vais employer 5 à 30 et du CFA de
Versailles donc je peux dire que j'ai
pas me plaindre mais je sais qu'il y a
beaucoup de confrères qui ont été très
touchés et j'ai eu des retours qui m'ont
franchement
fait mal parce que en fait les mecs ils
se donnent à fond et ça paye pas moi
j'ai cette chance ou ça a payé j'ai eu
de l'aide de ma conjointe de mes parents
et et voilà on a avancé mais on a vu le
retour il y en a qui travaillent et qui
n'ont pas ce retour et moi ça m'attriste
et bien merci beaucoup Gaëlle mollet et
Cécile perroté d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et pour être venu témoigner
sur notre plateau cape sur les Alpes à
présent avec Priscilla et Marie elles
ont la vingtaine et se prépare à
parcourir 750 km en six jours à bord de
leur 4L du 30 juillet au 5 août elles
devront réussir à relier
Bourg-Saint-Maurice à Menton nous avons
suivi leur préparation pour le raid
humanitaire des quatre Alpes
[Musique]
après avoir parcouru 6000 km lors du 4L
Trophy en 2022 les Sisters en vadrouille
Prescilla et Marie deux amis ont décidé
de repartir à l'aventure l'objectif le
catalp cet été 750 km en 6 jours de
Bourg-Saint-Maurice en Savoie à Menton
dans les Alpes-Maritimes en fait on
voulait vraiment pas comme je dis avant
laisser la 4L au fond du jardin et plus
la toucher peut-être être office c'est
un souvenir mémorable pour nous enfin
c'est une des meilleures expériences de
notre vie et quand on est rentré on
pouvait juste simplement pas s'arrêter
là donc on a décidé de repartir pour le
Défi sportif et pour le défi humanitaire
et tous les fonds de ce raid humanitaire
reviendront à l'association never again
qui lutte contre les violences faites
aux femmes et les inégalités entre les
hommes et les femmes top départ le 30
juillet mais pour être prête certaines
vérifications s'imposent on a plein de
choses à revérifier parce que les 4L
elles ont pris assez cher dans le désert
au 4L Trophy donc tout ce qui est déjà
dans la direction le train avant etc
tout ça il faut revoir parce qu'avec les
cailloux le sable ça on a tous ça encore
à revoir et au niveau du moteur il faut
qu'on fasse des vérifications pour tout
ce qui est le système de refroidissement
parce que on va avoir très chaud on va
être très haut en altitude on va y avoir
des grosses montées donc ça va être très
très dur pour pour la 4L il faut qu'on
ait toute la puissance possible que le
moteur il soit au top et la 4L ou la
titine comme elle la surnomme et déjà
bien peaufinée on a installé en bois un
système qui permettait de mettre des
matelas dessus pour pouvoir dormir la
nuit parce que des fois les nuits elles
étaient assez froides les gens qui nous
ont fait des dons nos proches etc et
donc ce qu'on a fait pour les remercier
c'est que sur le capot on a écrit tout
les prénoms de toutes les personnes qui
nous ont aidés financièrement nos
proches etc nos amis des montagnes des
lacs des falaises voilà ce qui attendent
les deux jeunes filles qui sont
impatientes de partir mais pour ça elles
ont encore besoin de quelques fonds et
de sponsors n'hésitez pas à vous rendre
sur le site internet juste en dessous
[Musique]
et nous avons été rejoints en plateau
par une autre journaliste de la
rédaction de TV 78 Gabriel Gontier
bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde avec vous comme
d'habitude le jeudi on vous partagez vos
idées de sortie à l'approche du week-end
quel est le programme ce soir et bien
Mathilde si vous n'avez pas pu profiter
de la fête de la musique hier alors
c'était hier soir comme beaucoup et
certains travaillaient le lendemain les
festivités se prolongent tout le tout le
week-end dans les Yvelines donc je vous
en parlerai dans quelques instants ce
sera dans notre partie loisirs mais
avant je vous propose d'ouvrir une
petite page culture l'espace Albert
Camus à Maurepas a révélé sa saison
culturelle pour l'année 2023 2024 et
pour nous parler de la programmation
l'adjointe au maire à la culture de la
Ville Véronique rocher alors pour cette
nouvelle saison vous avez mis l'accent
sur la musique on va avoir des concerts
de rock de métal de jazz et même du
gospel exactement
des années 80 aussi et du classique et
du classique en particulier avec
joaquimhors Sley qui est compositeur et
pianiste américain et qui revisite la
musique classique à la sauce caribéenne
en imaginant Beethoven Mozart mandalson
ou même Chopin ayant vécu à Cuba
justement je vous propose d'écouter un
petit extrait et on continue d'en parler
juste après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors là on a entendu la musique qui l'a
rendu célèbre c'est Beethoven in Havana
c'est un pari ambitieux de vouloir
mélanger le classique comme ça avec de
la rumba cubaine oui effectivement après
je pense que c'est aussi ce qui va
attirer
la musique classique quelquefois
n'attire pas beaucoup la jeunesse ou
même d'autres là je pense que c'est un
vrai défi quoi de de faire découvrir
redécouvrir ses musiques
Gabriel justement l'objectif c'est de
faire que la musique intéresse tout le
monde peu importe l'âge peu importe le
style qu'on a l'habitude d'écouter
exactement surtout que nous on a un
conservatoire qui est assez important à
Maurepas et donc on a déjà un public
important avec le Conservatoire mais il
faut l'élargir ce public
et donc voilà c'est un moyen de faire
découvrir à tous ces jeunes qui jouent
des instruments que on peut imaginer et
travailler autrement en tout cas au
niveau souhaité assister à ce concert ce
sera le 1er mars 2024 un autre
rendez-vous important un espace Albert
Camus Véronique rocher c'est Marianne
James elle va faire un one woman show
exact sur la voix exactement Marianne
Marianne James en chef de coeur pour
nous à Maurepas
humour et interaction avec le public
garanti cours de chant et conseils en
direct et donc c'est un spectacle aussi
interactif avec le public exactement
voilà c'est l'intérêt et l'enjeu de ce
one man show effectivement et donc
est-ce que vous savez comment est-ce
qu'elle va interagir avec le public
comment ça va se passer alors je ne sais
pas d'avance comment elle va se passer
si ce que j'ai déjà vu de ce qu'elle
fait déjà donc elle peut donner des
conseils pour dégager sa voix se mettre
en route
voilà c'est des petites choses comme ça
et puis après elle fait faire découvrir
aussi les tonalités de enfin bon voilà
en tout cas c'est rires garanti j'ai
l'impression j'ai l'impression aussi
garantie alors toujours dans le thème de
l'humour vous allez aussi accueillir 3 4
d'improvisation théâtrale c'est un peu
un rendez-vous à Maurepas oui depuis des
années c'est un rendez-vous ouais on a
un public fidèle qui vient chaque année
une fois par trimestre de découvrir ou
redécouvrir ce catch d'impro et alors
c'est quoi ces quatre d'improvisation
théâtrale alors c'est du théâtre mais
pareil du théâtre plutôt humoristique
souvent et qui peut être interactif
aussi d'ailleurs
donc voilà des personnages très
différents sur scène il va y avoir aussi
des personnalités dans ces quatre
d'improvisation puisque il va y avoir un
autre sa mère
qui est un très grand humoriste et donc
vous faites aussi la part belle au
spectacle jeune public pour cette
nouvelle saison c'est vraiment ce qu'on
souhaite d'année en année c'est vraiment
travailler auprès du jeûne public des
scolaires pour leur faire découvrir la
culture notre patrimoine
[Musique]
je pense que dans l'éducation c'est
juste indispensable et donc
allez-y non mais oui musique de pluie ce
sont les musiciens de Chapi Chapo qui se
donnent donc un samedi après-midi c'est
un concert de jouets électro époque
musique c'est un concert des années 80
qui redonne vie donc à cette à cette
décennie très joyeuse et très et très
insouciante voilà et on se retrouve au
milieu d'une chambre au milieu de jouer
et on découvre voilà toutes ces
redécouvrent toute cette musique on va
découvrir ensemble je vous propose
d'écouter un extrait là encore
[Musique]
alors on l'a vu sur ces images il
compose leur musique à partir
d'instruments joués au final c'est leur
marque de fabrique exactement ce sont
des jouets des objets insolites des
jouets vintage qu'on trouve quasiment
plus qu'ils ont amplifié et
donc voilà des mini synthétiseurs voilà
et il en résulte ce qu'on a entendu une
petite partition multicolore et voilà et
alors pour les plus petits aussi il y
aura un spectacle de marionnettes ou
alors une comédie sur l'histoire de
France oui de spectacles pour les pour
les jeunes publics oui effectivement
alors l'histoire de alors c'est sur le
ton un ton assez humoristique aussi ce
sont des deux personnages le professeur
et les et les lèvres on va dire qui
qui se questionne voilà plutôt sur un
ton assez humoristique effectivement et
on découvre un peu d'histoire un peu de
dates des dates historiques et
en apprendre un peu plus sur l'histoire
de France de différemment pour attirer
là aussi les enfants merci beaucoup
Véronique rocher d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
si vous êtes intéressé par certains
spectacles vous pouvez d'ores et déjà
réservé votre place sur le site internet
qui s'affiche juste en dessous de votre
écran allez c'est l'heure maintenant à
d'ouvrir une page loisirs dans votre 7 8
[Musique]
et on ouvre cette page loisirs avec vos
idées de sortie Gabriel Gontier on
commence par quoi ce soir du coup et
bien Mathilde aussi vous n'avez pas eu
l'occasion de danser hier soir pour la
fête de la musique il est encore
possible de le faire voici une liste non
exhaustive des villes qui prolongent les
festivités du côté de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et en cours
mais la musique à l'honneur avec un
concert année 82000 en guest Petro Pedro
Castagno qui nous fait danser sur la
Macarena ou encore Patrick Hernandez
interprète du célèbre titre Born to Be
Alive à mort pas les terrasses des
restaurants et des bars de la ville
accueilleront des musiciens du côté de
la verrière c'est une grande journée
festive qui est organisée avec des
animations et une soirée dansante et du
côté des pônes l'ambiance sera également
à la fête ce weekend oui la ville faite
le carnaval de la Saint-Jean au
programme retraite au flambeau soirée Dj
feu d'artifice mais aussi de nombreuses
animations bien évidemment vous l'avez
compris Mathilde vous êtes invité à
déguisé pour le carnaval et sachez que
le plus beau déguisement sera récompensé
dimanche la fête de la Saint-Jean vous
propose un rendez-vous inédit l'équipe
de France de Breaking viendra présenter
au public une démonstration de
breakdance en pleine préparation pour
les JO le spectacle risque d'être au
rendez-vous et justement on continue de
parler des Jeux Olympiques Gabriel
puisque le journée célèbre l'événement
ce sera au Golf National oui cette fois
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous propose
samedi une journée olympique ouverte à
tous vous pourrez venir tester une
trentaine de sport parmi eux du tir à
l'arc du BMX du breakdance ou encore du
tumbling vous savez c'est série
d'acrobaties réalisées par des gymnastes
aux cours de cette journée vous pourrez
également rencontrer des sportifs de
haut niveau enfin une visite guidée du
golf national sera proposée golf ou se
tiendront les épreuves de golf de la
discipline pour les jeux de paris 2024
on poursuit avec une idée qui pourrait
vous on nous rafraîchir avec les fortes
chaleurs de cet été oui si vous voulez
profiter d'activités nautiques ou tout
simplement d'un air de vacances pour
quelques heures les étangs de Hollande
ont réouvert situé au Brévières pardon
la première base verte des Yvelines
propose également un mini golf des
terrains de pétanque ou encore des aires
de beach-volley et tout ça au cœur de la
forêt de Rambouillet cette année marque
une réouverture en demi teinte tout
comme l'année passée les fortes chaleurs
et les précipitations Mathilde font
craindre une prolifération des algues
bleus dans la réserve naturelle et on
termine avec une activité Gabriel pour
les plus gourmands oui aux fermes de
Gally de Saint-Cyr-l'École la cueillette
des fraises a commencé l'occasion de
profiter d'une belle journée au soleil
et de repartir avec une récolte locale
et de saison je vous propose de regarder
le reportage de Céline Charles qui a
aussi bien profité de la cueillette
les confitures et des glaces de sorbet
comme ça soit en confiture des confiture
de fraises comme d'habitude quand on
parle de fraises chacun a sa recette
Sucré et légèrement acidulée elles font
le bonheur des grands et des petits à
l'arrivée des beaux jours aux fermes de
Gally de Saint-Cyr-l'École c'est à la
main que les visiteurs récoltent leurs
fruits j'adore la forme de Galil la
cueillette c'est hyper agréable donc on
peut s'y fait beau donc ils font
profiter si le principe de la ferme de
Gally permet aux gens de regarder ce que
c'est que la nature ça leur arrivée très
de penser que le lait ne se trouve qu'en
brique et non pas au pis de la vache que
les produits sont frais puisque on va
les faire les confitures tout de suite
on prend les biensûrs bon on sait ce
qu'on fait on sait ce qu'on pense
avec plus de 60 hectares les fermes de
Gally font de potager géant brouette et
sécateur à la main les visiteurs
viennent cueillir fruits légumes et
fleurs en fonction des saisons cette
année le temps clément a permis une
bonne production de fraises elles ont
été plantées à la fin du mois de janvier
il y a une vraie attente de nos clients
qui ont pas la chance de d'avoir un
jardin et pouvoir cultiver leurs fraises
mais qui veulent manger des produits de
saison des produits en circuit court et
des produits qu'ils ont cueilli attrapé
par la par la pédoncule par la queue et
puis vous ramassez là la fraise comme ça
on a l'habitude de classer les fraises
en deux familles les fraises dites de
saison qui sont en pleine production
maintenant qui vont donner toute leur
production de fruits en quelques
semaines et puis de la fraise dites
remontante qui commence à donner
maintenant et elles vont donner des
fruits jusqu'au mois d'octobre pour les
plus gourmands groseilles myrtilles ou
encore grillades pourront venir
agrémenter vos salades de fruits et pour
donner des couleurs à votre table les
listes rouges ou dorés sont également en
fleurs
alors justement un plateau est-ce que
vous êtes adepte des cueillettes et
surtout bah des cueillettes de fraises
ça fait longtemps que j'en ai pas fait
mais c'est que j'en ai fait petite bon
en général on mange plus que ce qu'on
récupère mais c'est sympa Mathis alors
moi je cueille mes propres fraises tous
les matins
et vous Véronique alors moi c'est pareil
j'arrive de Dordogne où il y a déjà
beaucoup beaucoup de fraises j'ai pas
besoin d'aller à Guéliz
je vous propose de continuer cette page
loisirs avec une autre idée de sortie
les passionnés de Botanic cette fois-ci
ont rendez-vous au château de Versailles
jusqu'à la fin de l'été le public peut
se balader dans le jardin du parfumeur
au domaine du Trianon cosmos chocolat
œillets de poètes ou rose de Damas près
de 300 variétés de fleurs ont été
plantés en partenariat avec le parfumeur
Francis curdignan le reportage de Julien
Leroy
[Musique]
les vrais roses utilisaient en
parfumerie odeur florale pétale rouge
vif ou d'un blanc délicat depuis le 30
mai le public est invité à s'émerveiller
dans le jardin du parfumeur situé au
coeur du domaine de Trianon à Versailles
dans cet espace de 9000 m² situé autour
de l'Orangerie de Châteauneuf près de
300 espèces peuvent être admirées par
les visiteurs pour une expérience
sensorielle
soit esthétique et
c'est quelque chose de nouveau surtout
parce que dans ces contextes ils peuvent
vraiment se balader en liberté dans
entre les massifs et c'est une chose que
c'est pas possible dans les autres
parties de domaine jasmin camomille ou
sureau le choix des végétaux s'est fait
en collaboration avec Francis kurgian
formé dans une grande école de
parfumerie à Versailles des variétés
sélectionnées pour leur fragrance et
planté dans l'esprit des jardins de
Trianon du 17e siècle
qui sont très parfumés quand on a fait
la conception on a cherché des des
insérer
des fleurs qui sont des hybrides récents
mais qu'ils ont à l'intérieur des points
de vue olfactive c'est une vitrine parce
que on n'a pas assez d'espace pour
produire la quantité telle est
nécessaire pour avoir une production
intéressante pour prolonger l'expérience
le château de Versailles organisé
également des ateliers pour découvrir le
secret de fabrication des parfums
présentation des ingrédients et des
méthodes d'extraction des connaissances
à acquérir dans ce jardin de curiosité
jusqu'à la fin de l'été
près d'un Français sur deux possède au
moins un animal de compagnie dans son
foyer chien chat lapin ou encore
oiseau il nous apporte réconfort et
compagnie au quotidien c'est ses
bienfaits que Christiane devit tant à
reproduire au sein de sa profession et
éducatrice spécialisée et médiatrice
animale elle se rend dans différents
établissements des Yvelines avec ces
animaux c'est le reportage de Céline
Charles
cannelle Heidi ou encore Joey ne sont
pas là que pour manger des légumes s'ils
sont présents aujourd'hui c'est pour
accompagner quatre enfants de l'Institut
médico-éducatifs le Castel de gazérante
alors t'as dit bonjour
[Musique]
Ombeline Sixtine Joseph et Killian se
rendent tous les vendredis dans cette
salle de Boissière l'école ils y sont
accueillis par Christiane de vie
éducatrice spécialisée mais ici sur ton
médiatrice animal elle met ses cochons
d'inde lapin et son chien à disposition
des enfants aujourd'hui on a commencé
par une petite séance de motricité avec
du découpage de légumes tomates
un geste trop brusque pas faire fuir
donc il faut apprendre à oui je fais la
statue je me pose et du coup le lapin il
va venir manger il aura moins peur donc
la deuxième partie c'était la séance
avec avec SANCA on était sur la
numération d'apprendre à compter
1 2
voilà c'est la 3
[Musique]
là c'est la fin de la séance du coup on
prend un petit temps où on se pose avec
les animaux on prend le temps de les
caresser de les laisser se déplacer un
petit peu comme ça on voit comment ça
bouge on peut toucher avec les mains on
peut toucher avec les pieds on peut les
poser sur le corps
comme Kylian qui aime beaucoup avoir le
cochon d'Inde en fin de séance sur son
ventre dépasser les sources de blocage
améliorer sa communication faire le lien
avec les autres ou encore travailler les
sens avec les différences de poils ou de
taille les séances sont pluriel et se
construisent en coopération avec les
éducatrices spécialisées du centre il y
a les enfants qui ont des peurs des
animaux et donc là avec Christiane on va
vraiment travailler comment on peut
amorcer
d'avoir moins peur en fonction d'animal
comment on s'approche de l'animal
ensuite on a des enfants qui sont qui
n'ont pas connu communication non pas de
langage et là pour nous c'est vraiment
un outil de média avec eux pour voilà
pour rentrer en relation avec eux à
travers l'animal pour pouvoir leur
apprendre
différentes manières de se tenir
christiane a lancé son association à
toute pâtes en 2021 elle et ses animaux
se sont formés à cette pratique il faut
pouvoir travailler et faire les choses
sérieusement en respectant aussi le
bien-être des animaux mais aussi les
personnes qu'on avec qui on va proposer
les séances pas faire n'importe quoi il
faut surtout les habitués à être
manipulés c'est surtout ça souvent la
crainte des animaux c'est voilà pouvoir
être malipulé pouvoir voilà
régulièrement les prendre leur faire
voir différents endroits à toute pas de
se déplacer
d'accueil médicalisé ou encore SESSAD
une méthode complémentaire au soin
traditionnel qui offre de nombreux
bienfaits et ce n'est pas cinq cas qui
va s'en plaindre
[Musique]
et je vous propose de continuer dans cet
esprit avec notre chronique sur le
bien-être animal
[Musique]
alors avec les fortes chaleurs qui vont
arriver cet été ATIS vous allez nous
proposer quelques conseils pour pouvoir
aider nos compagnons à quatre pattes
durant durant l'été et durant la
canicule notamment effectivement
Mathilde donc vous êtes venus avec un
petit chien un petit chien avec Bounty
qui était très gentil de venir
aujourd'hui malgré la canicule pour vous
donner des conseils effectivement même
nous les humains nous avons du mal
supporter la canicule et pour les chiens
c'est plus difficile puisqu'ils ont
moins de glandes sudoripares pour
transpirer c'est le fait de transpirer
qui nous aide à réguler la température
du corps et les chiens ben transpirent
essentiellement des coussinets et de la
gueule il est très sale Bounty il est
vraiment très très sage alors est-ce que
vous avez justement quelques quelques
conseils pour qu'on puisse les aider au
mieux pour les rafraîchir et oui Bounty
qu'est-ce qu'on fait et ben on sort très
tôt le matin beaucoup plus tôt avant
qu'il fasse très chaud plus tard le soir
Bounty par exemple est sorti hier soir à
21h ça lui évite de d'avoir basho au
coussinet avec le bitume qui est très
chaud vous lui faites de l'ombre à la
maison donc vous baissez les stores s'il
aime le carrelage bah privilégier les
endroits avec le carrelage et puis
changer lui son autre très régulièrement
même si la gamelle est encore remplie
vous privilégiez vous vous remplissez à
chaque fois ce gamelle quand vous sortez
bah sortez avec des gourdes avec de
l'eau vous avez des gamelles
transportables vous pouvez facilement
mettre de l'eau à l'intérieur
c'est intéressant ça et quels sont les
justement les risques si son animal a
trop chaud ou pas attraper une
insolation je sais pas les risques c'est
la diarrhée les vomissements donc
l'animal va être fragilisé et vous si
vous avez six risques là vous consultez
très rapidement le vétérinaire ça peut
être très dangereux donc c'est quand
même à prendre très au sérieux oui et
alors nous on utilise des glaçons pour
se rafraîchir l'été est-ce qu'on peut
aussi aussi utiliser des glaçons pour
les animaux et oui nous pouvons aussi
utiliser des glaçons pour les animaux
déjà le matin quand vous partez au
travail vous pouvez en mettre dans son
eau donc ça gardera son eau frais et
puis également dans son pâté le pâté
vous pouvez le glacer j'espère que le
pâtissier va être fier de moi j'ai mis
du pâté au congélateur Bounty vraiment
très sage je l'appelle la tentation en
même temps il adore le fromage lui ah
d'accord donc vous avez des techniques
vous avez des petits accessoires vous
pouvez mettre du pâté dans le
congélateur et puis bah votre chien pour
en manger tranquillement
vous prenez également ce que vous pouvez
faire c'est mettre un gant de toilette
d'abord au niveau des coussinets sous
l'animal et puis ensuite au dessus de sa
tête ce qui est bien donc Bounty lui
n'est pas en surpoids je le dis à chaque
fois c'est pas bon le surpoids pour les
animaux c'est plus eux qui souffrent de
la chaleur également le toilettage vous
n'hésitez pas à le brosser puisque les
poils qui sont en plus ça va donner
encore plus de chaleur
et puis on me pose la question
ventilateur est-ce que c'est bien ou pas
oui vous pouvez mettre le ventilateur
aussi mais il faut pas en abuser le
mettre au bon endroit faut éviter
également le pic de chaleur pour pour
les animaux et puis bah le la baignade
les chiens sont des très bons nageurs
donc faites des sports aquatiques et
puis donnez-lui le tout d'arrosage ça va
créer encore plus un lien de complicité
avec votre chien bon mis à part la
baignade j'ai l'impression que ce sont
quand même des des conseils qu'on peut
reprendre pour pour les chats par
exemple oui c'est presque les mêmes
conseils pour les chats merci beaucoup à
tous barré pour tous ces précieux
conseils j'espère que vous avez bien
pris note autour du plateau et puis chez
vous pour pouvoir aider nos compagnons
pendant les périodes de fortes chaleurs
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
mais juste avant de se quitter je vous
propose de jeter un dernier coup d'oeil
à la météo de demain
demain matin nous devrions avoir de
nouveau du soleil dans les Yvelines avec
quelques éclaircies au niveau des
températures ça reste toujours un peu
frais le matin il fera 18 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et Houdan et
17 degrés à Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi le ciel sera toujours assez
dégagé côté température et fera 25
degrés à Versailles 26 degrés à
Rambouillet et Houdan et 27 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et pour les prévisions
météo de ce week-end c'est désormais
Thomas Fletcher qui est à la
présentation il est allé dans les rues
et aller à votre rencontre et vous a
demandé vos ambitions sportives pour les
Jeux Olympiques de Paris 2024 écouter
alors quoi de beau
alors quoi de beau ce week-end dans les
Yvelines on retourne au base le même
spot qui va à la chasse perd sa place on
aurait dû rester
lundi c'est la journée des drogues
illicites donc on va pas spécialement en
parler parce que c'est illicite et que
ça interdit mais vendredi c'est la
journée olympique donc on va parler
sport et si on parlait sport ce week-end
on va voir s'il y a des potentiels parmi
vous
en ce moment il y a un peu d'orage c'est
dommage comme un ouragan
bonjour Chef comment vous appelez bien
Philippe bonjour Philippe bonjour
Est-ce que vous êtes au courant que ce
weekend c'est la journée olympique
il y a des quoi des choses olympiques
d'accord
avec des sports et tout ouais
est-ce que vous êtes au courant que ce
weekend c'est la journée olympique ma
foi non bon pourquoi pas mais les Jeux
Olympiques on en reparle un peu beaucoup
trop on est d'accord
pas trop déçu que la pétanque soit aux
JO monsieur
je m'en contente
monsieur
j'ai été sur les lunettes et tout
est-ce que vous saviez que ce weekend
c'est la journée olympique du tout et
bah avec plaisir de vous la prendre ok
ça marche pas tout à l'heure bonjour
bonjour
sachez que ce weekend c'est la journée
olympique
vous avez une belle cravate mais merci
il y a que la cravate
est-ce que
un sport lequel non pas du tout du tout
c'est dommage parce que là on voit il y
a un certain profil oui peut-être mais
j'essaye de ne pas perdre de trop la
forme est-ce que vous avez un sport de
prédilection là
qu'est-ce que vous avez comme comme
espoir
l'espoir de médailles
vous jouez pas
j'aurais pas pour les jeux ah bon
on peut se retrouver au 19 non
c'est le c'est le coup le coup à boire
après le parcours vous avez une passion
un peu sportive
non plus pour l'instant c'était la
course la course la course
de javiste
est-ce que vous vous seriez vu en tant
que sportif par hasard
le 100 mètres moi je vous y vois
je pense que vous mentez
le rendre j'en ai fait un bout de temps
[Rires]
vous avez là vous visez le podium quand
même sur le skate
alors est-ce que vous visez une médaille
déjà
ça veut dire est-ce que moi je vais
courir pour le podium
va falloir que j'essaye là si vous
pouviez ce serait quel sport là si je
pouvais la reine des prés
j'ai mal au coude
comme ça on fixe le gardien et on tourne
le poignet comme il faut donner un effet
au ballon qui retourne dans le but
les 10 secondes vous les avez là
force j'ai une descendez doucement vous
allez en faire quoi de la médaille ah
ben écoutez je vais la mettre dans un
cadre il a raison dans quelle pièce de
la maison vous mettriez une médaille de
olympique là pour tout le monde la voit
allez
alors quoi de
beau et c'est la fin de cette émission
merci pour votre fidélité je vous
propose de ce quitter avec des images
prises hier lors de la fête de la
musique dans les Yvelines je vous
souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]